nevada tax commission has partially  settled a legal battle with marijuana  companies  that were not given a dispensary license  the company sued the commission over the  way the  scoring system to award license happened  back in 2018.  most of the licenses were given to just  a few larger companies  the trial is actually going on at the  las vegas convention center  because there are so many defendants and  it has been dubbed  world war weed today the commission  agreed to settle with most but not all  of those companies the others said they  were left with nothing in the settlement  they plan to continue on with the trial  the district court and the  cannabis compliance board will still  have to approve that settlement